coup d'état samedi dernier à mon repas
évidemment l'événement n'a rien de
politique
il s'agit en fait d'un festival musical
organisé sur le stade du bois par une
association avec à sa tête francisco
star le directeur adjoint du café de la
plage que nous avons rencontrés dans
l'espace fille qui en six co star soit
plus simple que tu me tutoie dans le
rock il faut savoir qu'on soit tous mais
maintenant j'en doute y ait ici c'est
réservé aux artistes
donc ici tu es tu m'appelles de nous
confirmons la plage voilà c'est tant
mieux une piscine juste à côté et donc
il ya des loges tu vois il se retrouve
en échange loges
et puis on a même du massage la masseuse
qui met un cabinet pour se couper les
chouchouter artistes parmi les artistes
en question hubert-félix thiéfaine le
groupe arcisien deportivo ou encore
johnny montreuil un loup issu de la
formation princes chameaux style
directement inspirée par l'esprit dans
le noir des années 60
oui j'ai débuté ma femme un chameau
l'était avant voilà c'était le groupe on
a on a expérimenté des chaussées les
premiers textes les premiers trucs qu'on
faisait de la zique un peu
instinctivement il n'y avait pas
vraiment de style most à emprunter à
plein de choses il y avait là johnny
montreuil a déjà un truc beaucoup plus
directrices avec une grosse influence de
johnny cash les adaptations qu'on fait
lui c'est parti de là le projet est
devenu notre oeil donc des textes
carrément de johnny cash réadapter
complètement adapté librement adapté on
va dire bilan de cette première édition
du festival 1500 spectateurs soit 1000
personnes de moins que prévu
les organisateurs doivent maintenant
faire les comptes et se lancer dans la
recherche de nouveaux financements
s'ils veulent pouvoir de nouveau faire
roger moreaux tard